France what are some of the things that
you've done this week in your acting
career oh cool uh I was I was taking
this sort of like a Meisner class a
couple ways a friend of mine hooked me
up with it and I've been getting like
kind of like a private lesson
under the table a good friend of mine
working actor and it's good to do that
auditions since it's shooting this is
big time right now is shooting fact that
I have like a nine-to-five job it sucks
so I have to squeeze in whenever it's a
good audition for here and there like I
cook something last week but it's only
like a two day job but you take it I get
killed in it but it's alright it's
working damn it so do you have a time of
day that you work toward your acting if
you have a nine-to-five job yes that's
enough in itself right so when do you
choose to kind of say well I'm gonna go
on now casting when is searching for
jobs it's usually if it's not person
that I know that hooks me up with
certain auditions
it's ITEX certain sites but it's more I
get work because not having a manager or
an agent out here it's cool but it sucks
at the same time because they have all
the you know they tell you where to go
me I have to hustle for it I haven't
made that step up to it because like a
lot of my hacker friends are in the same
position I am yeah you're getting work
but you have to hustle for it so now
that's either you get that or you don't
it's playing it's tough it's tough but
yeah it's a tough situation
lost my train of thought for a second do
you see how a lot of people rely on a
generic manager just let me get them
working they don't do oh yeah I have a
lot of friends who are in like good
agencies so they do get the good
auditions but a lot of them get the
auditions but don't book the job so it's
like okay what else are you doing so
they found other avenues to do like
we've done like a bunch of short films
or you start doing webisodes then you
try to make stuff happen it's just as
now you know you played the game of is
it imposed Thor so there's different
avenues now because of those the
internet modern-day it's just that you
know to keep the bubbles moving we just
usually meet up and try to make
something happen that's all you really
can do if you're not getting auditions
to go make it happen we've talked to
other actors who say their family keeps
them grounded their dog keeps them
grounded their spirituality some guy
what keeps you grounded here so that you
don't get too caught up with whether you
didn't get an audition whether there's
hype surrounding whatever and look the
drama that comes with me I think the
whole grounding part of it I get humbled
every day because you see either a
friend or someone you got allies that
are just keep on working and working I
just go to my nine-to-five diet you know
day job and that's kind of like
motivation and stuff cause you're like
alright I can't do this anymore how do I
find my way into what I really love so
that just that's enough for me
you